so I do think therapy is something that
like there's obviously you know a lot of
people have uh starting to kind of break
down the I guess the uh
negative uh stigma about it m what's the
negative stigma I I just think I think I
think you know in the last decade or so
like it's been a lot more acceptable to
like openly say hey I'm I I'm going to
therapy I think before you would think
that there was something wrong with you
you know but it's not it's like
sometimes you need to kind of work
through like stuff that's subconsciously
there that you don't even know I feel
like everyone in the whole entire world
needs therapy I agree it's it doesn't
mean you're crazy or you're psychotic
it's I feel like because everyone in
this whole world's life is not perfect
and everyone has been through something
even if your life was like super good
growing up there's something there's
like something that you could maybe heal
from or maybe not I don't know maybe I
could be wrong but major majority of us
need something to heal from so 100% have
you ever uh done any psychedelics uh
what's that like shrooms or anything oh
I don't do drugs oh okay well I mean you
know some people say they're drugs some
people say they're not drugs they're
healing yeah I don't do drugs I Port I I
have I have smoked weed um before um and
I really didn't have a good experience
with it yeah weeds weeds whatever um I
would never in my life do a edible I see
people go crazy oh yeah don't ever eat
weed oh never it's the worst worst idea
so the thing about shrooms is like uh uh
there's like so they just legalized them
in Oregon last year I think mhm so like
uh veterans who have PTSD M they go
through psilocybin therapy and it like
it it really is like eventually it's I
mean I'm sure that it can help some
people don't get me wrong it's it's it's
going to be like a legal form of therapy
in the next like decade for sure okay so
drugs and therapy that's shrooms no not
not DRS like what what are shrooms
though is that like an actual mushroom
that grows from the ground correct
really yes the ones that we eat uh no
there's different types of mushrooms
obviously these are psychoactive they
have a ingredient called psoc well I
probably would go insane I probably
would probably die you might you might
but you might not um that's crazy
shrooms well shout out to you I mean you
I feel like I'm always impressed when I
see someone with a beautiful voice also
be a pothead really like you smoke a lot
to have to be able to sing like that
like yeah sometimes it helped the
raspiness of people voices true if you
got the raspy going I I get that you've
also kind of been like uh one of the
go-to like hook people I feel like for a
lot of rappers what has been like your
favorite hook you've cut that wasn't for
your own [__] for my own song a hook
um um I think you know I I did one for
Jeezy it's um Jeezy Benny The Butcher um
the real Hood songs I just like I like
being the bringing the sugar to the SP
or however you would say it like I like
being the sweet voice that comes on like
a real rough neck kind of song um it's
easy to do it with melodic rappers but I
I like to specifically do hooks on like
the thug thug do well cuz yo like in the
2000s that was the thing that was the
thing you would have like AER with an
amazing dope female singer or male
singer and it would be like a dope
record like even back when like I mean I
love Tupac like I grew up on Tupac my
mom loved Tupac so like the women that
he would have on there like just singing
They heart out I feel like if I was back
in that era that would have been me you
would been on the Tupac was is Tupac
like your goat my goat yeah who's your
favorite I never really said he was my
goat um who's my I mean he he's
definitely like a fave of mine like I I
have a lot of faves that are like OG's
like like Whitney Houston Whitney yeah
um but yeah I love love love Tupac who's
who do you think uh I think Whitney's
probably got the best voice ever best
voice ever um she has a very like very
powerful what her one of the best voices
Adele there too um Kiki Wyatt um for
sure her voice is insane of course
Beyonce's voice is insane Beyonce is the
goat but that's like I mean look
everybody knew that Beyonce is like the
best performer but Whitney's
vocal I just feel like you put a like
we're in a room there's no mics you just
got a belt just command the whole room
like yeah